اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير مشاهدينا
نحييكم الى بانوراما نناقش فيها كالعاده
ابرز ملفات اليوم وفي ملفاتي هذا المساء
الاتفاق الايطاري وفي السودان بين
العسكريين والمدنيين هل ينهي الازمه ويلبت
طموحات الشعب ولماذا رفضته بعض القوه
المدنيه في الملف الثاني مماطله الاسد
للقاء اردوغان هل سببها العداء الشخصي بين
رجلين ام ضغوط ايرانيات وما هي مصلحه
ظهران في تعطيل اي تطبيق للعلاقات بين
انقره ودمشق وفي الملف الثالث اعلان
الملياردير لهم ماسك الكشف عن وثائق تم
حجبها لنجل بيض انتصار لحريه التعبير ام
معركه سياسيه يخوضها نيابه عن الجمهوريين
ونحييكم الى التفاصيل بعد ثلاث سنوات من
الاضطرابات وقعت قوه سياسيه سودانيه على
اتفاقا ايطالي يهدف الى حل للانسداد
السياسي في البلاد فيما رفضته في المقابل
بعض القوات بينها الحزب الشجاعي وحزب
البعثه وحضر التوقيعه ممثلون عن الاتحادين
الافريقي والاوروبي والامم المتحده
والاليه الثلاثيه واللجنه الرباعيه
الاتفاق الاطاري على تنظيم انتخابات في
نهايه الفتره الانتقاليه المحدده بعامين
والتي تبدا منذ لحظه تعيين رئيس الوزراء
كما اشارت ابرز البنوك الى الاتفاق على
شخصيه المدنيه شرفيه لرئاسه الدوله وان
الصلاه
وان يكون رئيس الدوله القائد العمل الجيش
ومن ابرز البنود الاتفاق اطلاقه عمليه
شملله لكشف الشرائع محاسبتي مرتكبها كما
يهدف هذا الاتفاق الايطاري الى اطلاقه
عمليه شميله العداله وازاله تمكين النظام
رئيس المعزول بالاضافه الى ايقاف التدهور
الاقتصادي
[موسيقى]
هناك الشهاده الملف مع ضيوفينا من الخرطوم
محمد عبد الحكم قيادي في الحريه وتغيير
المجلس المركزي اهلا بيك وبعد قليل كذلك
سينظم لنا من الخرطوم الدكتور ادريس لقمه
قياده في حركه العدل والمساواه اهلا بك
سيد محمد سابدا معك وحضرتك من المؤيدين
لهذا
الاتفاق الاطاري رغم ان البعض الاخر او في
المقابل وصفه بالقول همم
بانه تجريب للمجرب قال البعض كماخذ الجبل
فولد فارا بان هذا الاتفاق هو عباره على
طريقه لانهاء فتره الثوره مرضه
في البدايه التحيه لك والتحيه للمشاهدين
الاعزاء في كافه ارجاع المعموره والتحيه
من قبل للزينهم من قبل الذين هم اعظم منا
جميعا شهداء الثوره السودانيه الظاهره
ولشعبنا الكريم السائر ضد الانقلابات
والتسلط والظلم وضد نظام الاخوان المسلمين
اللي سنوات طويله حقيقه اليوم هو يوم
تاريخي مشهود في تاريخ الامه السودانيه في
تقديرنا في القوه الحريه والتغيير تم فيه
انجاز تاريخي الضخم للغايه يمثل اشواق
وتطلعات الشعب السوداني وشارعه السائر في
انهاء الانقلاب في السوداني كلاب 25
اكتوبر والذي نامل عبر التوقيع الاتفاق
الايطالي في ان يكون اخر الانقلابات في
السودان لنودع حقبه طويله همم سلسله
الانقلابات حكمه ديمقراطي انقلاب حكم
ديمقراطي ننتهي هذه الدائره لنصل الى
الملتقى الرئيسي في همم دوله ديموقراطيه
همم زاد ديموقراطيه مستدامه التلفاز
الدخول الى تفاصيل هذا الاتفاق لماذا هو
اتفاق ايطالي وليست اتفاق نهائي لماذا همم
هناك همم وكان تحضير لامكانيه تعديل بنود
هذا الاتفاق هذا ما يقوله البعض لانه هذا
اتفاق بين قوسين كان المفروض التوقيع
عليهم منذ الخامس من ديسمبر اجل وحتى همم
بعد ما نشرت بنود وتسربت في الواقعه وطلع
عليها الكل اليوم اعلن عن همم اتفاق
انطاري وليست اتفاق نهائي لماذا
وهذا الامر تم اقرار بداخل هياكل الحريه
والتغيير عبر المجلس المركزي للحريه
والتغيير والذي يمثل برلمان واسع لقوه
الحريه والتغيير ومنه يتم التشريع ومنه
ااه تصدر الاوامر
لقياده الحريه والتغيير المتمثله في
المكتب التنفيذي همم تمت مرحله هذا
الاتفاق على اللاشيقين الشقه الاول هو
توقيع الاتفاق الايطاري
والشقه الثانيه هو
الاتفاق النهائي هنالك القضايا همم عاجله
يجب ان تحل بشكل عاجل وفوري
مثل نهائي الانقلاب بشكل فوري وعاجل
وهنالك قضايا وتشكيل استعاده الحكم المدني
بشكل كامل وتشكيل الحكومه مدنيه ذات راس
همم سياده مدني هذه قضايا عاجله لانه
هنالك كثير من الملفات على المستوى
الاقتصادي والامني والسياسي
صحيح هناك هناك اصلاحات على المستوى
السياسي على المستوى العسكري الاقتصادي
ولكن خلينا نفهم اولا اهميه هذا الاتفاق
الايطالي بتجهز معنا ضيفنا من الخرطوم
الدكتور ادريس لقمه قيادي في حركه العدل
والمساواه الدكتور ادريس اهلا بك معنا
ضيفي منذ قليل وصف هذا الارتفاع بالتاريخ
وقال بانه انجاز همم ينهي مرحله حكم همم
المؤسسه العسكريه وسيفتح الباب لمدنيه
الدوله وسيحقق خاصه مطالب المحتجين الى اي
مدى هذا دقيق
طيب شكرا لاخوه في قناه العربيه والاساده
المشاهدين اولا ااا هذه الاتفاقيه هي
تسويه لو نسميها حتى اتفاقيه هي تسويه
ثنائيه بين مكونات
اللي كانوا موجودين من 2019 وليس هنالك
جديد نفس المجموعه خرجوا همم لفتره وقتيه
وثم عادوا اليه اذا نظرنا الى الاتفاقيه
او التسويه بصوره عامه هي في الحقيقه هي
التسويه همم تم همم هندستها من قبل مجموعه
من السفراء ولا تمت بشيء الى وداني اهل
السودان او للتطلعات اهل السودان
دعونا نسال همم الذين كانوا بالامس يرددون
ويقولون بان هنالك انقلاب وغيرها فمن هم
الانقلابون ومن الذين قاموا بالانقافه
ونفس المؤسسه العسكريه الذين وقعوا معهم
اليوم الاتفاق همم الايطالي اذا ليس هنالك
حاجه جديده هذه الاتفاقيه واا دكتور
فقط لا افهم من حضرتك نقطتين ها هي تسلم
سلطه المدنيين هذه النقطه الاولى والنقطه
الثانيه ما اسميته هندسه اطراف لهذا
الاتفاق طيب فيما يضر ان تهندسه اطراف
ويكون في صالح الشعب السوداني لو توضح هذه
النقطه لو سمحت
هنالك لكل طرف مصالحه الخاصه في اطار
بتاعه تيسير هذا العمل وردتنا بانها مثلا
تكون اتفاق شامل يشمل كل مكونات الشعب
السوداني الان الذين وقعوا هذه الاتفاقيه
لا يزيدون عن الاثنين في المئه من جمله
الشعر السوداني واذا نظرتم اليوم هنالك
على الشوارع مغليه وهنالك رفض واضح لهذه
التسويه همم الثنائيه وان انا نرى بانها
لا لا تصير الى الامام هنالك كتله كبيره
جدا منها الكتله الديمقراطيه التغيير
الجزري النداء النداء النداء اهل السودان
والحزب الشيوعي او نداء الجذري وغير يروح
من المجموعات كلها
المقاومه
استاذ محمد ما رايك في هذا الكلام هل يمكن
القول باننا امام اتفاق ايطاليا
ااا ضيف يقول بانه لا يمثل الا اثنين % من
مجموع همم
السودانيين
هو حقيقه انه ساده العزيزه وهو تكرار
لاذاعه العبارات الشاهه التي كانت همم
مصدر سخريه السودانيين من قبل عناصر
النظام البائيد ولا اخوان المسلمين نفس
الغريبه نفس النسبه تم تحديدها من ضيفك
الكريم همم هي حددها قبل كده ال- ال-
الاخواني على الكاتب الصحفي الاخواني حسين
خوجلي بانه من يخرجون الى الشوارع هؤلاء
هم الاثنين في المئه وسناتيكم نحن
الاسلاميين ال 98% وستعود الى الجحور
وغيرها هذه اللغه عفا عليها الدهر
السودانيين يعلمون تماما بان من وقع على
هذا الاتفاق الايطالي هم يمثلون اغلب همم
الكتل السياسيه السوريه في همم في الواقع
وان هذه الاتفاق حمل همم مضامين همم
استهدف التحقيق كامل اهداف الثوره المجيده
وان هذا الاتفاق الان لديه اتفاق كبير جدا
من جماهير السوداني لانه جماهير الشعب
السوداني ترغب في انهاء الانجلاب وترقب في
اعاده الامور الى الى نصابه بحكم مدني
كامل وترغب ايضا في فضل الشراكه ما بين
مجموعه من المدنيين الذين كانوا اا يعني
حولوا انفسهم الى ادوات للعسكر يحركهم
كيفما شاء منهم هؤلاء الذين الان يتحدثون
عن ان هذه الاتفاق يمثل 2% فقط هم عملوا
مع ال مع الانقلاب الذي خرج الشعب
السوداني منذ فجر الانقلاب ضده همم فكيف
بهما الان يتحدثون عن ان هذه النسبه هي 2%
هؤلاء يريدون استمرار الوضع احكام القوه
النظام البائد والاخوان المسلمين استعاده
مقاعدهم مره اخرى في المؤسسات ليكونوا
شركاء معهم ومع المؤسسه العسكريه الان نحن
في الاسكندريه
بتاعي حرام هؤلاء الذين اتفاق فقط لالخص
من يعارض هذا الاتفاق هم من يدعمون
المؤسسه العسكريه يدعمون بقائها هم من
يدعمون بقاء الاخوان في السلطه همم وهم من
يحرصون على عدم الايفاء بالوعود في داخل
همم السوداني
هذه حديث ينكره
هؤلاء الذين اليوم ذهبوا همم اتفاقيه او
الاتفاق العقاري مع المؤسسه العسكريه هم
ذات المجموعه الذين حكموا البلاد ووقعوا
الاتفاقيه خان والشعب السوداني خانوا
الانتفاضه وقوا مع العسكر همم
اتفاقيه واستمر ذلك لمده عامان في حياتنا
العامين ما قدموا اي شيء فكان كل ما تم
تقديمه هنالك فقط همم اختلاس الاموال
الشعب السوداني
وفساد وغيرها والان يريدون تكرار نفس
المشعر هؤلاء ليس لهم همم لديهم همم مقدره
همم لتحقيق اهداف الشعب السوداني ولا
تحقيق الثوره وحاولي معروفون لا ياتي
احدهم لا ياتي احدهم للاشخاص ولكن ما هي
الانتقادات التي تحملونها لبنود هذا
الاتفاق يعني هل هناك قله ثقه في امكانيه
تنفيذ هذه البنوك يعني ما هي الانتقادات
التي تخص المضمون
طيب
تاتي اساس انتباعا على الذين وقعوا على
هذه البنود هؤلاء كما كما ذكرنا من قبل
بانه مرفوضون من الشعب السوداني ما حصل في
باشجار وما حصل في غيرهم هي كانت ظاهره
فاذا هم حاربوا من الشعريه هي هروب من
الشارع واحتمال بالاسكر الان لكن اذا اذا
نظرنا الى بنود الاتفاقيه نحن قلنا هنالك
وثيقه تم اعدادها من خارج البلاد والان
اتو به دعونا نجلس مع بعض جميعنا وننظر
الى ما ما يحويه همم الاتفاقيه او ما
يحويه الوثيقه ثم يتم تشريحها واضافتها
ونقصها وعزفها وغيرها الى ان نصل الى
الصيغه المرضيه ولكنها حول هذه لن يظهر
حتى بنود الارتفاع من حاول وكثير جدا
مخفيه حتى المجموعات الذين وقعوا
الاتفاقيه اليوم كثيرون منهم لا يمر على
الوثيقه لا يعرفون ما في داخل الوصيغه فقط
ثم
بعدهم وهمم
طيب ولكن خليني اقولها لانك هو تحمل صحيح
ولكنك تحمل شيء من اللوم على اقصاء بعض
المجموعات سيد محمد لماذا تم اقصاء بعض
المجموعات وبينها حسب او حركه العدل
والمساواه
لم يتم اخصائيه اي احد بل هنالك من اثر
الابتعاد واغصان نفسه حتى البارحه كنا
جلوس مع حركه العدل والمساواه وكنا يجلس
مع حركه الجيش تحرير السودان في قياده
التامين ناوي والعدل والمساواه بقياده
جبريل
وقدنا نقاشات طويله من اجل ان يلتحقوا
بقاطره الاتفاق الايطالي ولكن لديهم همم
لديهم اشياء لا اعلمها يريدون بطبيعه
الحال يريدون استمرار الوضع كما هو انا
ايش فيك حقيقه على همم على حديث همم الضيف
في الجانب الاخر لانه ليس لديه اي تحفظ
على اي بلد من الجنود الارتفاع هذا واضح
تماما من خلال النقاش نحن نتحدث عن محتوى
شامل همم التنبه فيه ويرجاء قضايا محدده
تحتاج الى ناشونال جي بي من كل السودانيين
لتحديدها سواء على مستوى التفكير كبير
الاخوان المسلمين ال- ال- نحن نتحدث عن
بنود الان البنود تلبي اشواق وطموحات
الشعب السوداني هؤلاء الي يريدون تلبيه
طموح وطموح الشعب السوداني ولا يريدون
البقاء في السلطه ولو على اجساد الشهداء
حتى ولو تراكمه الجثث في الخرطوم الى الاف
لا يعنيهم نحن يعنينا اي قطره في السودان
تعمينا يعنينا ابعاد اييي اي عنصر منتمي
لجماعه الاخوان المسلمين المنتمي النظام
البايت اي عنصر يعمل مع القوات
المسلحه كيما تبقى في السلطه كانجلابيه
هذا يعنينا يعنينا بشكل كبير انه يجب ان
يتم تصحيح همم الرؤيه السياسيه بالنسبه له
والسودانيين الان يرغبون في حكم مدني كامل
شفاف حديث عن انه هؤلاء نهبوا الثروات همم
قدمنا الى السجون وتم اغتيال قياداتنا الى
السجون لم يجددوا اي ماده يتم على التشكيك
في في نزاهه اي منها نحن ليس لدينا راس
مال سوى حب هذه البلاد والعمل من اجل هذه
البلاد لم نخل ولم نسرق
وهذا المتحدث همم يعلم تبعهم بانه هو كجزء
من الانجلاب ستطاله يد المحاسبه والشفافيه
في الدوله القادمه دوله الحريه والعداله
والسلامه التي ستتخم عن هذا الاتفاق
الايطالي الذي في تصورنا سيعيد السودان
مره اخرى الى العالم الاقليمي والدولي
انواع الاستاذ محمد هذا نوع من انواع
التهديد لما تقول بانه همم نحن نوافق على
همم الاتفاق الاتاري وستطال همم يده
العداله كل من لم يوافق بما فيها ضيفه
دكتور ادريس
لا لا لا لا لا لا
فقط
لكن في الحقيقه
اختي العزيزه وساده
[تصفيق]
في جانب الاخر الذين وقفوا معهم الاتفاق
اليوم هم العسكر هم المجموعه الذين اخذوا
الانقلاب كما يقولون من قبله
فيتركونهم في اتجاه ثم يقولون نحن نحاسب
الذين ساعده الذين مجموعه اللي كان معهم
في الانقلاب فهذا هو دينهم في في حته على
التسويق وفي في الكذب
همم
وتغليف الحقائق بالصوره اخرى هؤلاء هروله
ووقعوا مع نفس المكونات العسكري على همم
وثيقه الدستوريه
ودماء همم الشباب شبابنا العزيز همم في
الانتفاضه لم تجف
بعدما يقدمونه الشباب
على على على على على ظهرهم فنحن نقول بان
اننا نقاوه اننا نقيم هذه الاتفاقيه كل
الكتل كل المجموعات الثوريه في داخل
السعوديه
بملعب الفم لن تصمت هذه الاتفاقيه طويله
وفاء فقط همم
10 ثم جرى مع نصل
نحن مع احترامنا لكل ضيوف الحاضرين معنا
هي وجهه نظر مختلفه طبعا كل وجهه نظر تعبر
الاكيد عن شريحه مجتمعيه او شكرا لكم
جزيلا شكرا على المشاركه وطرح هذه الارى
من الخرطوم الدكتور ادريس لقمه القيادي في
حركه العدو والمساواه ومن الخرطوم كذلك
همم محمد عبد الحكم قيادي في الحريه
والتغيير المجلس المركزي شكرا لكم